foreign
Garden in Urbana and talk to Claire
what's up Claire
hey how are you partying dude what are
you up to
oh you know
is it raining today
it is actually the first time in a while
if you could do me a huge favor and go
holler at your baseball team tell them
to just take 30 off and back it down a
notch my Astros are in danger not making
the playoffs because your boys came out
of nowhere so just send a nice note and
tell them to just chill out okay what's
up
so I've been listening to your show for
a while and I guess I've heard you talk
to several people about
I guess um
living in a fantasy when it comes to I
guess accepting the reality of
the person that's right in front of you
and I wanted to talk to you a little bit
about
if I'm doing that or if I'm seeing the
potential in somebody and supporting
their growth in life in in the context
of a romantic relationship sure tell me
more I something happened and that's why
you called what happened
well you know we've been dating for two
years now and
from the beginning I knew that you know
he's prone to a lot of anxiety and
depression
and when he's really feeling those
things it's like this Dark Cloud that
follows him around you know he's quick
to anger he's super defensive he can be
really cold and like just negative and
it seems sometimes even like suspicious
of me that I'm gonna hurt him you know
in some way when I'm just trying to be
caring and
on the other side of that when he's not
feeling that you know everything is so
great he's playful and loving and I feel
so cared about and
and he's I really encouraged him to seek
help
um and he's been going to therapy and I
feel like things have
I guess gotten better but you know I'm
also particularly sensitive
person and so you know if he's short
with me
it just feels so heavy sometimes and I'm
like man is this gonna be
is this am I gonna is this gonna be like
this
forever
and sometimes I it just feels
overwhelming and I think do I just need
to accept this
is who he is is like a cold short person
or
am I actually like investing my time and
energy into helping him
grow and
build a relationship
does that make sense yeah totally
um
can I say a couple of hard things and
you push back if I'm wrong
yeah
think of me like you're at the doctor's
office and it's like does it hurt here
does it hurt here that's what I'm doing
right now okay
um I think there's something else
what's this something else
um
how dark are those dark moments
I mean
I guess what bothers me the most is like
oh when he's angry he raises his voice
and sometimes he'll swear and
that's really triggering for me yes so
here's that's what I was getting at
it's not a matter of him having anxiety
it's not a matter of him having
depression
I know loads of people myself included
who have those traditional Diagnostics
that have great relationships
but they're a context they're not an
excuse to scream and swear and cuss at
somebody you love
and Beyond the raising your voice and
swearing he scares you
yeah and so I just tell you my house
well let me even before I even tell you
about my house I don't want you to look
at this relationship like it's a bank
account that you're trying to invest
over the Long Haul
like he's not he's not a mutual fund
yeah the question you need to ask
yourself is do I feel safe and loved and
seen and heard and still loved anyway
in this relationship
not if I do a bunch of the right things
and keep pushing him and grooming him
and coddling him and okay for the
occasional like oh you're great for the
occasional ray of sunshine
in the next 15 years well this finally
all go away answer is no
yeah because he's not a mutual fund
in my house my wife and I came to the
understanding that my refusal not to not
be anxious because that's just my body
trying to get my attention not to be
running really low
that was my body trying to get my
attention
but my unwillingness to go way upstream
and change the way I do things
um
that was the problem
and so when we sat down and said hey
if we're going to both feel safe in this
relationship if you're going to be the
man that I know you can be and I'm going
to be the most plugged in wife that I
want to be
um here's what I need from you
and it wasn't to not be anxious it was I
need you to take care of yourself
I need to put the computer down I need
you to sleep I need you to never scare
me in my house right and and she didn't
say all those things I'm just I'm
speaking in her language
um into your home
the conversation is if he won't go do
the things he went to counseling which
is great that means he's sitting down
talking to somebody is he then going to
the gym
is he then going to work a second job
to pay off what he owes is he then going
to do these things that's going to give
him peace in his home
that's the bigger question
what say you
well
um
I don't know that's a lot it is it is
how about this
have you been completely clear and
honest and direct
about what about what you need
what you want and what your boundaries
are
yes I feel like I have this okay
have you enacted those boundaries for
instance if you yell and swear at me
you are through your behavior kicking me
out of my own house and I will leave
or kicking me out of the apartment
and I will leave
well I'm just having a low episode you
don't even care no no no no no no your
low episodes are not an excuse to treat
me like garbage if you're having a low
episode it's your responsibility to step
out go get the help you need go with the
care you need go do the things that help
you be well and hold be honest with me
not use me as a as a living embodiment
of a Xanax to try to make you feel
better that's not my job
yeah and that's what I worry about
because I
responsibility on myself
I guess
soothe in that ways on me yeah because
you're his mom now
yeah you're like a pet owner you're a
mother you're not a girlfriend
is that fear
yeah yeah
like there's no such thing as a perfect
person and there's no such thing as the
one those are all Hollywood myths so
it's not real that's actually way before
Hollywood but they're not that's not
real
the question you have to ask yourself is
is this person doing whatever they can
to help me meet my needs so that I can
do everything I can to help meet their
needs so that they can do everything
right are we both in this together so we
can build something amazing or yeah
am I still on the road trying to change
tires
and when I talk about like a fantasy
somebody sits down and says hey John
I've got this idea for a business
the idea for a business is
um a group of people
um everyone people can have cars and
they're just going to be connected on
their cell phone and you're gonna be
able to hit a button and that person
who's closest to you is just going to
swing by and pick you up
and we're gonna handle money over here
electronically so there's not even an
exchange of money you don't even tip in
person
and I'll do a whole bunch of background
checks on the person over and over and
over again to make sure they're safe
no more taxis no more you having to park
downtown no more any of those things you
just hit a button on your phone
someone's gonna swing by and pick you up
if someone explained that to me that'd
be awesome I'd say I could see how that
could work really great
there's going to be a lot of Regulation
a lot of things we have to do to get
there but I can see it
and when my daughter brings me her
wooden helicopter idea built out of a
out of a
like some sticks and a chair and some
rope I can see it
I can also see
that's not gonna work
so let me ask you a hard hard question
are you done and you're just trying to
give yourself permission to be done does
your Roi language suggest I heard a
comedian say the other day the worst
part about a long-term breakup is you
get no future credit for that in the new
relationship you can't be like you can't
meet somebody new and be like no no I
already went to all the weddings like I
did that like you got to go to the other
weddings now right you got to do it all
over again
um and somebody with an Roi mindset
sometimes find themselves in
relationships long term that they should
have left a long time ago
um
but they've deposited so much in the
account they don't want to lose that
sunk cost
yeah are you done all right
sometimes in those moments when
they're low I feel like
that I don't really trust myself to make
that decision because I've had a
tendency to run away when things are
hard before okay I love it I do too
I have a bad tendency to cut and run
in fact one of my mentors told me once
he said the worst thing you've done for
yourself is giving yourself so many
options you got so many degrees and so
many credentials and so many experiences
that you can just cut and run and you
never have to live through something
when it's hard
and only when you put in the work during
the hard season do you get this amazing
Harvest on the back end
but if you cut and run and every time
you show up it's just when they're
picking apples you don't like to sit
there through the drought man you don't
get to see the super Harvest on the back
end and he was right he was absolutely
right I cut and run and so what I've
learned to do is I Outsource that before
I quit my job as a senior student
affairs officer I flew across the
country sat down with two of my oldest
buddies and said I'm thinking about
quitting all this to become a podcaster
and a YouTuber does that sound smart and
they were like you're nuts and that
sounds right
like you're gonna get to travel around
speak write books get on the road help
people
it's nuts but it's right
I was too close to it
yeah do you have some women in your life
that know you've been going through know
your boyfriend know how your your
tendencies that you could sit down and
be completely honest with
yeah I do
would you be willing to honor them and
you by saying hey I need to go for three
hours on Saturday morning I'm gonna lay
this all out
and let them speak into your life a
little bit
yeah I can do that I think that would be
awesome at least give you some clarity
and tell them I promise I won't get mad
and I won't do classic Claire or I try
to over explain myself or whatever your
classic moves are
um yeah but give them permission I'm not
seeing this clearly
um and I talked to this goofball
podcaster and he suggested that I get a
different opinion from people who love
me
but I think that's where you're at
here's here's my super fear I think in
your gut you know
and maybe you spent a lot of years
learning to shut that inner voice up
or maybe this is the time too your
invoice is wrong either way I think you
know
the question is
do you all agree about the need for a
change and are you both taking steps
however wobbly or wonky towards those
changes towards that new tomorrow
and if you're doing that and you're in
then that's awesome
my wife has been there for me as I have
had to completely relearn how to be a
grown-up and I've probably done that
three or four times and I've been there
with her when she's made her changes
that's the nature of relationships
but it all starts with an agreed upon
here's what I want this house to feel
like here's what I want my marriage to
feel like I want to be warm I want to be
hilarious I want to be safe I don't want
to walk into my apartment and feel
scared
that I don't know what mood you're going
to be in
I can't control that I know you're right
so your work is how do we get way
Upstream of that and begin the healing
process there
cause you deserve somebody that doesn't
scare you somebody that doesn't swear at
you somebody doesn't scream at you you
deserve that
regardless of what their diagnostic is
let me know how that conversation on
Saturday goes I'd love to get some
feedback on that and let let me know
what those uh women you trust say
but I think you know